viens donc ce qu'on voit en tous les cas
à la lumière de cette anecdote relatée
dans l'air incroyable c'est qu'en fait
c'est un petit peu dans votre vie
quotidienne un petit peu comme au cinéma
non non on va voir on va faire une
interview dans la vraie vie
concentrez-vous temps sans tabou et lui
aussi est ce que dans la vraie vie il
vous arrive de vous jouer la comédie
l'un à l'autre non pierre
non non jamais non non bon enfin non non
franchement il ya inscrit son nom n'a
pas besoin a besoin bah non nous on a là
on allons là on à la comédie et on ouvre
la porte de la maison pibou mal comme
idée derrière la maison vous êtes comme
en bas la maison n'a pas besoin de ça
autre chose il jouerait là la maison je
t'aime
non non je n'ai pas de tee shirt tu es
vraiment naze
alors peut-être une commande pour la
prochaine fois est ce que est ce que
dans la vraie vie vous arrive d'entendre
des applaudissements dans les moments de
tendresse
oui pourquoi
il ya sûrement des coups de théâtre dans
votre vie emeline détroit qu'on est ce
que dans la vraie vie frappe les trois
coups et ça ça compte
j'essaie de tant que faire se peut dans
l'avenir la brigade
alors là c'est pas là la sefa lamentable
a t il restait deux tranches de
transformer la vie tant que faire se
peut en tout cas le quotidien comme
quelque chose qui est plus magique est
plus mystérieux et plus agréable et plus
rigolo tant que faire se peut alors ça
c'est important est ce que dans la vraie
vie vous fait relâche le lundi
pas du tout a dit non est ce que dans la
vraie vie faisait déjà trouver un amant
dans le placard non non donc c'est pas
du tout du tout du tout comme au théâtre
finalement la vraie vie pas vraiment non
à l'entracte
est ce que dans la vraie vie pierre il
ya une scène que vous ne vous lasserez
jamais de jouer avec evelyne y en a
plusieurs
oui oui je dis oui on va y en a au moins
une nuit bien sûr ma cassette sk une
scène dans la vraie vie que vous voulez
plus jamais jouer avec evelyne il ya des
scènes que je n'aimerais pas avoir à
jouer avec evelyne quoi par exemple les
scènes qu'on jouerait bien honnêtement
pour revenir vers ses précédents il ya
des scènes que je rejoins là il a des
souvenirs car je ne vous je ne vous
lisiez jeune fille dont nourrir le
parking l'énigme du parti en dehors de
la chambre ont la loge et tout ça quand
on nous a collé les panneaux endroit et
cuisine la cuisine la buanderie
je crée buanderie pierre venir pas du
tout
on était très voiture nous voilà voilà
voilà voilà temps après pour la revente
on a eu de très joli retour de tournage
en boit cul